you
or someone you care about may have been
diagnosed with ovarian cancer
this video will help you understand the
treatment options available
ovarian cancer begins in the ovaries
which are the part of the reproductive
system
that makes and stores eggs cancer occurs
when abnormal cells grow out of control
the cancer cells continue to divide and
may spread
your treatment is based on the type and
stage of your cancer
and other important factors
the main treatments for ovarian cancer
are surgery and chemotherapy
your treatment plan may include both of
these options
you may also receive one or more of the
following treatments
targeted therapy immunotherapy
radiation therapy or hormone therapy
surgery to remove the tumor is often the
first step
in your treatment plan the goal of
surgery is to treat your cancer by
removing as much of the tumor as
possible
if you have epithelial ovarian cancer
the goal
is also to stage your cancer
surgery includes removal of one
or both of the ovaries
the affected fallopian tubes may also be
removed
if the uterus is removed surgery may
include taking the cervix
to remove as much cancer as possible the
surgeon may need to take tissue from
beyond the reproductive system
lymph nodes or the omentum which is the
apron of tissue that covers your stomach
and intestine
may be taken
surgery may also involve taking tissue
from nearby organs such as the bladder
stomach or colon
chemotherapy uses drugs to fight cancer
the drugs enter your bloodstream and
travel throughout your body
chemotherapy works by killing cancer
cells or stopping them from dividing
healthy cells in the body may also be
affected leading to side effects
targeted therapy is a treatment for
advanced epithelial ovarian cancer
it targets the part of cancer cells that
makes them
different from normal cells these drugs
change the way cancer cells divide grow
and repair themselves as a result
the tumor may stop growing or even
shrink
nearby healthy cells may also be
affected leading to side effects
immuno-oncology also known as
immunotherapy
helps your immune system fight cancer
these treatments strengthen your immune
system so that it can
find and attack cancer cells or stop
them from growing
other treatments for ovarian cancer are
radiation therapy and hormone therapy
they are used less frequently your
doctor may prescribe a combination of
these treatments
discuss with your doctor any questions
you have about your treatment plan or
side effects
be sure to take your medications as
directed by your doctor